I am so thrilled that I can now talk
about something I alluded to a couple of
weeks ago and it already was actually
posted to the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t sam cedar on his program yesterday
spoke about the fact that right winger
steven crowder chickened out of a debate
with him at politican and we can put the
post up just so people can see and
indeed when a couple of weeks ago i said
i have stories for you guys that i will
hopefully be able to tell about
right-wingers who chickened out at
politican this is what i was referring
to and i wasn't going to talk about it
before sam spoke about it
sam has now spoken about it and indeed
steven crowder who loves to debate
college kids on campuses and say changed
my mind
apparently didn't want to debate sam
cedar because it would not have gone
quite as well what up this can't be true
this can't be right steven crowder is
all about the open exchange of ideas
that changed my mind guy let's let the
best ideas win and respectful exchange
well sam is issued issued a challenge to
him which i don't necessarily expect to
be answered but sam tells the entire
story of how steven crowder and
apparently I guess steven Crowder's dad
is sort of like his manager in some way
and they decided it would not be a good
idea for him to debate sam at politican
and they just stopped responding to
politican he didn't do anything there
and nobody heard from him to be fair
that's probably true it's probably a bad
idea for steven crowder to the debate
saying I actually agree with the
assessment it definitely is also from
the David Pakman show subreddit that I
noticed Freudian slip from FoxNews yet
when Fox News started reporting on the
suspicious package sent to CNN they
mistakenly said that a suspicious
package was sent to CNN containing some
kind of white power and of course they
later corrected it and said that it was
some kind of white powder and it's it's
there is something very clever and
interesting to the Freudian slip there
white power was connected to this and
the the receipt of these suspicious
packages I think that there's something
to that
honest mistake I'm sure but it's just
very funny coming from Fox News
join the discussion more than 70 to 73
hundred of our viewers and listeners now
subscribers
free on the david pakman show subreddit
at I forgot to silence my phone once
again today at david pakman.com slash re
d di t i've got to do better with the
silencing of the phone so unprofessional
i gets spam calls all day every day and
i usually i'll just silence it right now
before we move on because i respect the
audience so much i don't want to have
that happen again today's program was
made possible in part by Blink esteem /
pakman i love bling kissed it's the
really perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the david
pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
says is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
esteem slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about five
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up